in akron ohio the anger is rising and
these protesters say they will stay on
the streets until there's justice for 25
year old jalen walker who was shot dead
by police last monday
he was probably one of the most positive
people i ever came across in my whole
entire life
so when i first heard the news it was
like
i thought they got their names
officials say the incident began when
officers tried to stop walker for a
traffic violation
akron police say walker fired a gun at
officers who were chasing him after he
fled that he presented a threat to the
force
they plan to release body camera footage
later on sunday
[Music]
but a lawyer for the family says that
footage will show officers shot walker
dozens of times
some who've seen the video have
described it as graphic shocking even
barbaric
we really need to utilize the word keep
to peace
because when the people see what
is going to be shown in that footage
it's going to cause some problems and it
will go through nationwide
the shooting is the latest in a string
of police killings of black americans
that many say are unjustified
the 2020 murder of george floyd in
minneapolis ignited global protests
against racism and police brutality it's
the hypocrisy we have a problem with if
this was happening to everybody in our
community we would not care but it's not
happening to everybody
the officers involved in walker's
shooting have been placed on
administrative leave while an
investigation is underway
alexia o'brien al jazeera